two weeks ago I was in the pet shop and
I saw a dog toy here and I got really
excited and I bought one in fact I got
so excited that I asked my wife to go
back later in the week
and buy a second one so now I've got two
and so now I'm going to tell you why is
the chemist I find the Pentagon
five-sided molecule like this so
exciting ferrocene is a very very
special compound and it's special
because it established an entire field
of inorganic chemistry which we call
organometallic chemistry and that
concerns the chemistry of compounds
where you have carbon bonded directly to
a metal this is a very good
representation of C 5 H 5 this molecule
here or species C 5 H 5 is chemically
very unstable it doesn't exist for more
than a tiny fraction of a second without
reacting with something but if it has an
extra electron C 5 H 5 minus it becomes
very stable it will become an iron in
solution it can form salt and the
chemistry of this is really quite
fascinating ferrocene itself is what's
called a sandwich complex and that means
that you have a metal and it's
sandwiched between two planar ligands
the reason why C 5 H 5 - became exciting
to chemists was that in the early 1950s
the chemists called
No can I can I call you back in well I'm
just making a video bye the reason why
it's interesting is because in the 1950s
a chemist Peter Paulson took a salt of
iron metal and reacted it with these and
made a new compound that was bright
yellow and when he analyzed it it had
one atom of iron and two of these rings
and he thought about the structure and
thought it had the shape like this with
the Rings joined together with the iron
looks rather like a pair of psychedelic
glasses like that it turned out that he
couldn't really rationalize explain all
the different properties of the
compounds based on this structure and it
took a different chemists Geoffrey
Wilkinson to realize that the structure
was much more exciting like all great
molecules or inventions it was stumbled
on by accident but it was Woodward and
Wilkinson and Fisher who first proposed
its structure which was revolutionary at
the time no one ever thought that these
ligands could bind to metals in this
kind of way
the iron atom was sitting in the middle
of two of these rings just like the ham
in the sandwich between two pieces of
bread it was so like a sandwich that to
this day these are called sandwich
compounds and so this compound tea of
ferrocene has become a really iconic
compound the first of many many
compounds with different sorts of rings
with different things joined to it and
so on so what I'm going to do now is
just turn on this link line just so that
we have some vacuum available
because we need to put the tube where
the ferrocene is in under vacuum we're
going to attach it to this slink line
and the reason we need to do that is we
need to put a tube and a vacuum because
if you heat it under one atmosphere it
won't go anywhere but if you take away
the atmosphere then it can survive the
tube much more easily and once people
understood this structure they realized
that you can make all sorts of other
compounds with just one of these rings
for example so if you take this here
which you can imagine is niobium with
four groups on it you get a stable
compound with just one ring on the top
some people call these piano stools
because it has a place to sit and some
legs but I'm not sure whether this is a
very good example of a piano stool okay
so we're just evacuating the tube now
just why the pumps making that horrible
noise so this is a heat gun this is
basically just what you buy in any DIY
shop if you want to peel the paint off
your walls but they're really handy
because they're very good at heating
things for short periods of time so what
we're going to do is we're going to heat
this ferrocene and what we should see is
that it should disappear and reappear up
roundabouts here
because it's going to sublime the hero
of this was of course Wilkinson because
he discovered that what was before
chemical oddity was a start of a whole
new area of chemistry so-called
organometallic chemistry organic part
and a metal but so he got the Nobel
Prize he shared it with the German
chemist EU Fischer and Peter Paulson
became quite famous but never got the
prize I've always felt very fond of
Peter Porton because the very first
conference I went to as a student
happened to be in Moscow I met Peter
Paulson and I still have a photo which
shows him and me sitting close together
at the conference in fact I'm sitting
next to Peter's wife Mary who was
Chinese and so I've always felt a great
affection both for the compound and for
Peter it's just because there's you're
just heating it so you're giving your
energy and you've got the thermal motion
going through
you can actually see smooth it now
building up at the back here that will
go away in a little bit
actually it hasn't gone as far as I
thought it works it's only getting into
this section here but you can see it's
now growing here quite significantly
so here the molecules are getting enough
energy so they can break out of being a
solid and go straight into the gas phase
and because this whole system is under
dynamic vacuum they're being pulled up
the tube when they're in the gas phase
but then they lose their energy so they
go and find the newest wall and cling to
it and then form right there and that's
what it's doing so it's subliming right
from here to there and as the heat rises
up you can see this bottom boundary is
starting to fall away because now those
molecules are getting energy back again
and they can supply off again so then
they're going a bit further up the tube
it's gone so what we did was we put some
ferrocene in at the bottom and then we
heated it with this heat gun and it went
from being a solid to a gas so it rose
up the tube and then it lost its energy
that we gave it from the heat gun so
then it crystallized again it went
straight back to the solid phase and
stuck to the walls of this test tube and
that's sublimation